[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is ambassador Luis CdeBaca he's an
American lawyer and diplomat who served
in the Obama administration as
ambassador at large to monitor and
combat trafficking in persons he is at
Yale as the robia Fellow in modern
slavery at the Gilder Lehrman Center for
the Study of slavery and abolition at
the Macmillan Center as one of the
United States most decorated federal
prosecutors ambassador CdeBaca
investigated and prosecuted crimes of
human trafficking immigration hate
crimes money laundering and official
misconduct he updated the post-civil war
statutes and the Thirteenth Amendment to
develop the victim centered approach to
modern slavery which has become the
global standard for combating human
trafficking through the trafficking in
persons protocol to the United Nations
organized crime convention today we'll
talk with ambassador CdeBaca about the
work that the Gilder Lehrman center is
doing on modern-day slavery and his work
on transparency in supply chains and
enforcement welcome ambassador it's good
to be here thank you so let's start with
your work here as a row being a fellow
tell us about what you're doing well
I've been taking advantage of a lot of
the things that yell has to offer
especially the archives there's some
wonderful archival resources as far as
cases that were done a hundred years ago
during the Roosevelt administration Taft
administration even then up into kind of
the lead into the world war two under
Roosevelt and so looking at those and
seeing kind of what in effect my
predecessors in the Civil Rights
Division at its beginnings we're doing
to go out and investigate and prosecute
those who would still hold someone in
slavery
85 90 years after this
okay and if the GLC the Gilder Lehrman
center is kind of I won't say moving
away but incorporating more research and
work on modern-day trafficking modern
slavery kind of moving not a way towards
the antebellum slavery but incorporating
more to more of the modern-day
trafficking that's going on throughout
the world so what kinds of things are
they incorporating well one of the thing
I'm looking at modern slavery as well as
kind of trying to bridge the gap between
the Civil War and pre Civil War chattel
slavery the organized legal structure
that was both political and social in
the United States that changes in 1865
but one of the brilliant things about
Thirteenth Amendment is it doesn't just
say it's over as of today it actually
says and it never will be replicated so
it says neither slavery nor involuntary
servitude shall exist and that second
part is really what I've worked on in
government and it's one of the things
that fuels the gl C's work as far as
modern slavery how is it that the
framers of 13th amendment the
abolitionists that the GLC has been
renowned for studying for having such
insights that you know David Brian Davis
and and others I'm certainly David Blake
now the director I have been able to
bring to those actors but then what are
the parallels that we see in the modern
era what are the fissures between the
different parts of the modern
abolitionist movement some people want
to deal mainly with sex trafficking of
US citizen children other people want to
see the issue as through a gender lens
as far as migrant women and states were
kind of you know how do they regulate
that migration others want to look at
through a prostitution lens and still
others want to look at it as an
opportunity to fight for labor rights
for all people in America and overseas
all of those things together are very
redolent of the wonderful terrible
squabbling
of the abolitionist movement even to the
point of when you look at the slave
narratives whether it's Frederick
Douglass or Harriet Jacobs writing about
their experiences and if you kind of
overlay them with what people are saying
now in the last twenty years when
they're coming out of say for instance a
brothel in a immigrant serving community
or a house where they've been held as a
domestic servant the ways that people
unfamiliar with the slave narratives of
150 years ago describe their own lived
experience is so redolent of what
escaped slaves would say about what was
happening just like a universal thing
exactly and I think the GLC is in a
particularly good position to be able to
make that leap you know it's not just
the Gilder Lehrman Center for the study
of slavery it's slavery resistance and
abolition and that notion of the ongoing
resistance what does the Thirteenth
Amendment mean in an era where we don't
have legal formal systems of slavery one
of the things that the GLC recently did
was to have a conference where we were
able to bring in people from around the
world scholars mainly but some
practitioners to really kick the tires
on this what is working it's been almost
20 years since the United Nations
protocol since the American trafficking
Victims Protection Act updated those
post-civil war statutes and 18 years on
where are we what's working what's not
working I would like to get into that at
some point to see what your ideas on you
know what can be done but I am curious
to know and I think many people aren't
really in tuned to the fact that it is
such a huge global problem can you put
it in perspective with some numbers
perhaps of course the estimates that are
out there
tend to range a bit but I tend to look
at a ton of 24 to 27 million as the
figure that I would take to the bank
there's a figure that goes up to about
40 million that involves the recent
addition by some researchers and the ILO
at the International Labour Organization
I'm trying to capture
the related issue of child marriage and
forced marriage if you backed those
forced marriage numbers out the numbers
seem to be around 25 to 27 million which
if you compare that to Antebellum
slavery not just in the United States
but in the entire hemisphere you're
talking about maybe four million folks
who were brought from Africa during the
the slave trade whether to Brazil
whether to the United States what's now
the United States the Caribbean Basin
etc so the numbers are greater but of
course there's a lot more people in the
world I think one of the things that's
different now though is that entire
societies are not based on this
everywhere in the world pretty much
everywhere in the world slavery is
illegal now that wasn't the case in the
Gulf states it wasn't the case in Saudi
Arabia within living memory and so those
countries or places like Mauritania and
Mali who are just now making it illegal
the age-old practices of hereditary
slavery they're at a very different
place than most other countries but what
most countries are having to do is 100
or 150 years after they abolished legal
slavery they're having to confront its
presence in their society so there's
that moment I think for policy makers
around the world where everybody says oh
my god it's happening again right or
maybe it never stopped happening we just
stopped looking for it and that's I
think you hit the nail on the head there
because I mean though that's a 25
million that's a huge number all around
the world and even in the United States
it's happening and you people say how
can that possibly be happening in this
country
so shed some light on that how is it
happening in the United States well it
happens even in countries like the
United States where there is rule of law
and where corruption is not the norm and
where the economy no longer depends on
it like the southern agricultural
economy depended on it up until about
the 1940s that's not the case anymore
but the reason why I think there's these
echoes of slavery and you see people who
are being subjected to practices that
directly violate the Thirteenth
Amendment even today is if you have a
combination of
vulnerable people and greed and cruelty
that's kind of the recipe for this
witch's brew of enslavement it could be
a family that brings a young girl over
from West Africa with promises of a
better life and going to school in
America suddenly that 13 year old is
walking the other children to the school
bus and turning around and going back
and working in their home as a maid to
knock on the door at night from the man
of the house or the older sons I think
tells us that sometimes our ideas that
sex trafficking and labor trafficking
are totally separate maybe doesn't
necessarily line up with the lived
experiences of a lot of women and girls
who find themselves into this situation
but it can also be something that's much
more open if we would only see it while
we drive by it so if you're in the
fields in South Central Florida if
you're going through the pine forests
where people are doing the reforestation
and actually ask the workers you know do
you have a debt are you paying off that
classic old company store debt by the
end of the week you owe more than then
you ever would have been able to pay and
the folks over at the law school did a
case with the pine workers a few years
ago where you know under the guise of
environmentalism the big forestry
companies were going out and having
people plant new trees but those men
were enslaved so I think that we have to
look at some of our baseline assumptions
whether it's around sustainability
whether it's around environmentalism
whether it's about you know kind of
where we are in the world and then start
with the the first question which is are
the people who are doing it slave or
free mm-hmm and what led you to this
line of work well I went to the Civil
Rights Division of the Justice
Department fresh out of law school I
worked on in the criminal section of the
civil-rights division which is where the
prosecutors are and the three main
things that you do in the criminal
section civil rights are all flowing
from the constitutional rights typically
from the post-civil war constitutional
13 14th and 15th amendments and so we
look at please misconduct you know so in
other words police brutality really it's
gotten extra to you frozen so police
brutality racial violence which now has
thankfully expanded to look at hate
crimes and bias crimes motivated by
gender sexual orientation religion etc
not just race and then of course
involuntary servitude with slavery and
at different times over the last hundred
years the each of those areas have taken
the bulk of the sections work in the
1950s and 60s it was very much in the
Mississippi Burning years it was very
much about trying to take down the Klan
and the entire system of lynching and
violence in the south in the 80s and 90s
I think there was probably more
attention to police brutality in many
ways human trafficking and which is the
new kind of international term and it
takes us back to the work of the 30s and
40s the anti peonage years but now what
we really see is my former colleagues
are having to deal with all of them
simultaneously because in a globalized
world slavery is back as we are able to
see more of what police are doing in
their encounters with civilians we are
recognizing that there's a lot more
police brutality out there than people
knew and the specter of racial violence
never goes away so I was in in that
section it's about 30 people and you get
to be the guy from Washington who comes
out to local places and tells them what
to do which makes you very popular in a
lot of places around the world but what
it does is it really puts you on the
forefront of these promises that were
made in 1865 and thereafter as far as
the federal government's necessity to go
out and insist that these constitutional
protections apply to vulnerable
communities and so that's kind of how I
ended up doing this I specialized I
think more because they needed there
weren't that many spanish-speaking
attorneys as you got more people from
the Asian and Latino communities coming
into the government and then
in roles like this I think a lot of us
came in and we looked at things with
they're fresh and new lens you know
saying you know this is happening on our
communities because we know it from
talking to our cousins and just knowing
our own history and so there was kind of
an insistence I think on the part of a
lot of that Latino and especially Asian
and South Asian lawyers that this is
something that we wanted to work on as
well as working on quote-unquote
traditional civil rights and do you
think the problem of human trafficking
and slavery is on the rise or do you
think it's being held at bay you know
it's hard for me to tell I mean I think
that one of the things that we're seeing
is that there's no good numbers the
prevalence numbers are people are
working very hard to try to get this
good social scientists many of whom are
now finally starting to look not at
things that are biased by enforcement
numbers enforcement numbers could be
totally skewed simply by what the
priorities of that local law enforcement
office is if if they have somebody to
speak Spanish then their numbers will
end up having a bunch of cases that have
spanish-speaking victims and if they
don't they may never actually identify
those cases so there's some new
prevalence work that's being done by
sociologists and anthropologists around
the world that are trying to use some of
the predictive things that are coming
out of the war crimes and genocide space
and that's really interesting we haven't
really started to kind of bridge the
gaps from Gilder Lehrman Center which is
up till now been I think much more of
kind of a History Center it's very much
the mission but at the same time I think
we're starting to see now with some of
the different fellows that have come
through to the GLC recently and with
some of the work that we're hoping to do
in the coming years very much bridging
the gap over to the sociologists the
anthropologists the business school I
guess here it's the school of management
as well as even the folks in from the
public health over at the Medical School
I think there's a lot of ways that we
can start to put together that knowledge
base so that we can answer that question
in the future a much more
interdisciplinary kind of approach to
solve the problem exactly
but prevalence aside you know one of the
things you know Bill Gates famously said
a couple of other donors in the
anti-trafficking space that he'd take a
pass on doing work in this and work on
malaria and other things because he
didn't feel like this was countable yet
and of course that's the problem it's a
hidden crime people's suffering in
silence that don't come forward and
unlike domestic violence or sexual
violence we haven't necessarily come up
with the proxies yet so that we can come
up with a number to answer people like
gates and others to say yes we can
measure this and therefore we can see
whether it's up down sideways and
whether any particular intervention
really is making a difference across the
board what we do know though is that the
individual intervention that you make
when somebody goes out through a window
and seeks help if you have the policies
in place so that they aren't going from
the firing pan into the fire so that
they're incorporated into government
protections into nongovernmental
organizations service providers even
though that's a one-off that's not a
systemic fix you know to me there is
that that you know kind of saying that
everybody has as far as you know in each
individual life is the universe and I
think it's the same thing that you know
if we can do right by one trafficking
victim at a time eventually we can have
that universe of freedom right right I
am wanting to talk about the term victim
centered approach to modern slavery and
how it's different from what was
previously done so let's talk about that
a little bit well typically in most
legal systems including the United
States a person who suffers a crime is a
witness they were often called a
complaining witness so you talked about
your CW in law enforcement it's slang as
opposed to this idea that they're a
person who had been victimized by what
happened to them they were valuable more
for being for what they could tell you
about the crime as opposed to that
something had happened to them the Civil
Rights Division prosecutors I think came
from a little bit of a different place
because we were having to vindicate the
rights that had been violated it wasn't
that the interest of the United States
in not having houses burned down his was
being violated when somebody who would
do a racially motivated arson it was
that family's interest under the First
Amendment and Fourteenth Amendment in
being able to live in an integrated
neighborhood without being subjected to
violence and so I think our set point
without knowing that this was kind of
you know it's like asking a fish about
the water right our sweat point or our
set point was very much we start with
this person's rights were violated and I
think that out of that Q flowed the
victim centered approach which was you
know we are here for what's best for
them if it's a child victim and they
might not be able to testify because of
trauma we either come up with another
way to prosecute the case or we charge
something that's not really going to
require that child to have to testify we
have to bend to allow when I say we I
mean law enforcement has to bend to
allow nongovernmental organizations and
advocacy groups the church others to
come into the case and have a level of
power that you never would allow in an
organized crime case or a
money-laundering case or something like
that and so a lot of the victim centered
approach is kind of resetting the
criminal justice response so you really
are putting the victim and their needs
at the center it's not that you're
providing them housing and psychological
services simply to get them to be a
better witness for you it's you're
providing them housing and psychological
services because when you're trying to
put together somebody's life after their
rights have been violated and you as the
state are the guarantor of those rights
then it flows from that that you should
do those things to make them whole or
even better than they were before the
trafficker got them so I think that a
lot of the victim centered approach is
simply you know where you stand and look
and if you stand with the victims and
listen to them I think you end up having
that instrumentality of a better case
yes but more importantly the entire
ethos of the work that you're doing
changes right and and that makes sense
and I'm wondering how well that's been
accepted in this country it has in fits
and starts obviously just a few weeks
ago we saw the the commutation of
sentence of a young woman who had been
in Kentucky I think I had been in prison
for 15 years after killing a John a
client she was an underage girl who was
in prostitution therefore under the
American law and the UN was
automatically considered a trafficking
victim you don't have to show that
somebody's will is over born if they're
under 18 because just like with
statutory rape there's this idea that
somebody that age can't consent to be
involved in commercial sex and so go
back you know a couple of decades and
here's this fifteen-year-old girl who
ends up killing one of the men who's
raping her let's not use euphemisms as
to what the the clients of underage
people in prostitution are doing and I
think that we saw just you know whether
it was online or otherwise in much of
December and early January of this year
a real outpouring from people saying no
she should not be in jail for what she
did so I think that it's it's getting
out there in the culture I think that
that ethos is happening you know people
are not just being seen as oh that's an
illegal alien or that's a prostitute you
know one of the things that we heard at
the GL sees modern slavery conference in
November was just how for most of the
20th century even the FBI who was
supposed to be investigating these cases
would look at a case and say oh well you
know she's got a bad reputation in the
so we're not gonna bring the case it's
like well of course she has a bad
reputation in the community her pimp was
putting her out on the street through
force threats of force or because she
was underage in fact that's the case
that law enforcement should be running
towards rather than running away from I
think that that cultural shift is
happening but we have to keep the hammer
down right right so how do we shine the
light on those shadows on modern slavery
what are some things that need to happen
I think women to turn the culture and
make a difference I think one of the
things is to look at kind of what has
worked in the past one of the the most
effective things in the British Empire
as far as abolition was concerned were
the boycotts of sugar from the West
Indies and so you had consumer activism
at a time when people didn't even have
labels like consumer in the early 1800s
where people were actively shunning West
India and sugar now that created a
market for colonial sugar that was
coming from East India and in which you
know displacement effect there was a lot
of other abuses and and and things from
that but as far as what it did with that
particular slavery in the Caribbean is
is that it really started moving towards
the endgame when you had British
consumers who were making their
decisions with their pocketbooks it got
the attention of not only the sugar
growers but it certainly got the
attention of their bankers that's a lot
of what we're trying to do right now in
the anti-slavery movement in modern
times but not just in one sector so it's
like do that but then do it in fish in
palm oil in garment in labor or
construction electronics you know you
name it so what we've been able to do
not just in the United States and law
that California passed a few years ago
but also in the United Kingdom and just
recently
in Australia along on both the British
and Australian laws I was able to work
with some of the parliamentarians and as
we were coming up with it but that
basically requires companies to file
publicly what they're doing to trace and
ameliorate abuses within their supply
chains now what I hope it also does is
it provides fodder for academics and
others to go and then and maybe even
lawyers to go look at the company's
disclosures and find out whether they're
actually doing those things what is it
that a fortune 500 company publicly says
that it's doing versus what we know when
we go out and talk to the workers you
know start to kick the tires on that but
up until now there hasn't been anything
to compare against so the modern slavery
act in both Britain and now Australia I
think are revolutionary when it really
comes down to it so what other things
because you're working with supply
chains and intrigues me where I can see
boycotting certain products certainly
would work but it's hard because we
don't really know what to boycott I mean
I think it would work better on the flip
side if someone is going and looking at
companies and actually seeing who the
workers are but then I guess there's not
enough manpower or resources to keep
track of that so what exactly are you
advocating well I think that one of the
things that we see is that because there
are so many things that are tainted by
slavery if we want to live eat clothe
ourselves you know all of those things
in the modern globalized economy then
the reality is that we will end up
having something to do with slavery
ourselves every one of us one of the
things that hopefully the students in my
class my first class meets tomorrow and
so there Rita had exercises actually to
go online and take their slavery
footprint which is a great little
website saving slavery footprint org
where you can go on and take about a 10
minute survey of what you own and what
you consume you know what's in your
medicine chest you know all those types
of things and it will tell you based on
some you know algorithmic work that UC
Berkeley did for them it will tell you
roughly how many people in forced labour
around the world it takes to sustain
your lifestyle so I'm really interested
in having you know Yale undergrads have
to confront their own not I want to say
culpability because if all of us are
culpable then it's a systemic issue that
we have to look at but you can't solve
it by yourself by suddenly saying well
I'm only gonna you know we're you know
tunics that I've knitted by hand from
the two sheep that I own and you know
even that probably would have something
so I think that one of the things that
we're looking to to harness is that
interest that then goes up to whether
it's government's or whether it's
businesses to be the ones that do it
they know their supply chain better than
we do and you know one of my lasting
memories in Thailand and the fisheries
was that they kept saying well we can't
tell you which boat the shrimp came from
because you know that's just tracing the
supply chain way down you know way too
far down and so a couple of people from
my office from the State Department
we're out at one of the ship shrimp
packing sheds and first the workers
always said well we don't like it when
you come because the bosses always warn
us the day before that you're coming and
so then we don't bring our children and
we have to get childcare I don't think
that that was what the boss is one of
the workers to say to the American
diplomats but you know that is the
reality but the second thing is that one
of my one of my staff noticed that there
were barcoding
on the trays the big tub plastic tubs of
shrimp
and they were you know hitting it with
the bar cutting machine and she asked
what what's going on they're like oh we
have to do that because the American
Food and Drug association or Food and
Drug Administration requires us to be
able to know where the shrimp came from
in case there's a health outbreak these
are the same companies in a country
where the government and the companies
had been telling us oh we can't trace
this back to the actual vote it's like
they didn't want to trace it back to the
actual
for this purpose hmm the question that
that raises to me though is why doesn't
the United States Food and Drug
Administration has the power to look at
that then why doesn't the Customs and
Border Protection have the power to do
that so that we don't bring in slaves
made goods and so as a result President
Obama issued an executive order doing
just that
and we were able to get with Senator Ron
Wyden and others a change to the tariff
act that made it clear that you couldn't
import slave named Goods and so now
tracing down to the boat tracing down to
the farm and actually requiring that
they look at their supply chain if they
expect to bring things in the United
States that's becoming a reality
and we are very happy to see actually
that one of the people from US Customs
and Border Protection one of the folks
who's setting up that office and is
gonna be doing the frontline work
actually came up to the GL see what
works conference which you know I think
that that's when you're putting on an
academic conference and suddenly field
practitioners start showing up you know
I think it shows that you're really on
the right track right well thank you so
much for being here today and sharing
some of your work and we'll look forward
to seeing more from you in the future
and thank you for more information about
ambassador CdeBaca please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at you
you